what's going on there reject nation we
literally just got out of the batman if
you're here if you can leave a like
that'd be very much appreciated you know
we gotta talk about our instant thoughts
and emotions or feelings because there's
a lot to unpack here this movie is
almost three hours long for a reason and
i'm still processing i'm sure john is
too we're both still processing a lot
because there's no i think i know what i
did i think i knew exactly
one word review this movie is so
different than every other live-action
batman movie that has ever existed if
you guys stick around for some of our
trailer reactions commentary part of it
you'll probably heard us say from time
to time i'm expecting a little bit of a
slower film something that's much more
deliberate what surprised me was it is
so much more of that so much more to the
point where i found myself occasionally
getting pulled out going you want to
talk about no more lies matt reeves was
not lying my first thought was it's kind
of like if francis ford coppola produced
a remake of chinatown directed by david
fincher that took place in the batman
universe and was written while a guy was
listening to nirvana that was my first
thought yeah it wasn't just like halfway
it's pretty spot-on i think nicholas
wind in refn but not as slow
yeah
speed in half and take all the synths
out and there you go so the story takes
place in batman year two where batman is
more known as vengeance a mysterious
presence that criminals fear but is not
quite viewed as a hero by the citizens
but especially not by the cops this
movie deals a lot with batman's position
in the world is he a vigilante who
punishes criminals or is he a hero can
he be both so as established in the
trailers the story's kickoff point is a
murder mystery where a popular figure in
gotham is murdered and the serial killer
leaves many riddles often being one
specifically delivered to batman one of
the many amazing things about this movie
is it is purely what matt reeves said he
wanted this film to be it's a pure dark
psychological drama and i cannot stress
that enough the marketing team
specifically put out these three comics
which was batman ego long halloween and
batman year one it is so much of those
comics but also such a 70s movie at the
same time yeah it really leans into the
to the film and and neo-noir aesthetics
and just the approach to unraveling the
mystery and the psychosis that onsets
for everyone in the process of doing
that while the action is good that's
certainly not the main takeaway the main
takeaway is the storytelling the mood
the rot tension and turmoil this
ensemble but especially what batman is
going through it has this incredibly
executed escalation the tension-filled
build is in a gritty bleak world where
the mood is really captured through the
soul of gotham it's a time to straight
up horror movie but primarily a film
noir detective murder mystery film and
in many many ways it's the most pure
batman movie ever made the movie is so
cold yet by the end of it i was also
like some of the most emotional i've
ever been in a batman movie like i did
find myself like really moved to tears
it's kind of insidious in the way it
creeps up on you well yeah they let the
cinematic language speak where i feel
like a lot of movies and a lot of batman
movies let the scripting and the graphic
novel inspiration speak whereas this one
does have moments that are just tonal
and are just the pure magic of cinema
through the lens of batman that are
quite moving in a very unique sort of
way there were so many aspects of this
movie that has a lifelong batman fan i
found myself going like
they're doing things i started getting
misty-eyed early on because i was like
they're doing the things that i've
wanted to see in batman movies done
before the first 15 to 20 minutes of
this movie is easily the best 15 to 20
minutes opening of any batman movie just
my opinion but i stand by it robert
pattinson as batman i feel like you
essentially got like two different
performances here you got bruce wayne
and then you got batman he is mainly
batman in this movie i think it'll take
audiences a little bit of time to adjust
especially to like who he is as bruce
wayne i mean the way he plays batman i
think is just so
awesome is he badass yeah of course
what's unique though is he's sort of
like an alien observing humans it's a
very detached performance but again
that's a compliment similar to ryan
gosling's performance in drive this
character is immensely observant empty
but with a rage underneath that like
menacing coldness it's more batman ego
less batman year one where the effects
of year one have really weighed on him
into year two simultaneously it's mainly
a private investigator emotionally
broken and tormented detective portrayal
with batman robert pattinson talks so
much about how and in some ways batman's
kind of a freak he's a weirdo you watch
the trailers you're like batman's such a
badass everyone just views him like
weirdo in an outsider but he's an
ultimate badass then you watch this
movie you're like that's kind of a weird
guy yeah that's what it would take he
wouldn't actually be the billionaire
like hey guys and then want to go out
and be the same kind of batman that
we're all used to and yeah as much as
there is like a
clear duality i thought there was also a
great connective tissue between bruce
wayne and batman you can tell all the
parts of bruce wayne that inform the
batman that come with him when he puts
on the cape and the cowl and then all
the parts that are left when he takes
them off i thought that was a very
wonderful and you know cold interplay a
really fascinatingly hewn character yeah
that would be a reclusive odd kind of
distant guy yeah there is a distinction
but also it's the most they've ever felt
intertwined to me and of the same root
or not like one is simply a veneer to
hide the other like they both feel
integral to the way he plays the
character and it felt quite unique in
the array of on-screen batman and bruce
wayne performances that we've seen thus
far for sure it's definitely unique matt
reeves talked about how he really was
inspired from like kurt cobain and
listen to a lot of nirvana while writing
this movie and so much of bruce wayne
does feel like okay i see all that
inspiration it feels so like punk grunge
type of portrayal of bruce wayne so much
of that performance in his eyes
so engrossing yeah like in the world of
the movie he draws all the energy in and
when you're watching him on screen he
draws every eyeball to him the whole
supporting cast is so good you can name
everybody like everybody brings such a
presence and feels so distinct and they
are a great ensemble together i mean
even though there are certain characters
that you want to see and that you're
looking forward to they all feel like
integral pieces of the puzzle and
everybody brings their a game like
everyone's got multiple moments that
really grab you paul dano as riddler i
mean look paul dano he's phenomenal all
right elements of the zodiac killer
elements of jigsaw and it's a very
realistic take of what this genius
high-level intellect killer would be
they really treat him like an equal
counterpart to batman i would say where
their goals of uprooting the corruption
to gotham are similar but their methods
are just much more different he's just
as obsessive if if not more and is way
more demented it's just kind of weird
how the trailers hide him so much but
they put him in interviews
i know he's like you're not gonna see
his face right he's like we're gonna
yeah we're gonna get to know a lot about
them
but i appreciate that they went to the
effort at least doing that in the
trailer does add to this sort of like
larger than life persona that does kind
of have an interesting effect on you
when you're actually watching it unfold
and discovering what the true
circumstances are on screen freaking uh
selena kyle zoe kravitz definitely an
origin tale for her some of the biggest
emotional weight is most given to her
out of a lot of the characters i would
say there's some big surprises to be had
with her you know talks and articles
about like can't she have her own
spin-off show
yeah i think she can yeah i'm just gonna
say yeah i would watch
yeah just great chemistry with robert
pattinson i wasn't like in love with
like oh batman and catwoman i wasn't
like feeling that like such a weight of
romance and the way how the the movie's
going for that film noir femme fatale
kind of quality but i still think zoey
kravitz herself as an isolated performer
is really good and overall their
chemistry robert patterson's strong john
chituro's karma phi falcone was one of
the biggest surprises of on-screen
presence here it's like not surprising
if you know his his work but in terms of
like a standout character jeffrey wright
as uh gordon you know some people when
they saw the trailer would sort of
compare it to morgan freeman and brad
pitt it's not that
no not at all definitely not but but
jeffrey wright brings something so
refreshing to gordon himself of course
he has that older man qualities because
of what jeffrey wright is there's also
something that feels more relatable
about his performance but he uses his
dialogue like little things like him
going like hey man you need to calm down
like things like yeah yeah little very
little
remarks that he'll make yeah and that
are also kind of informed by his very
relatable like
what i love one good cop well what i
love so much about her was it really
felt like him and batman were doing
detective work together a lot of the
time it can just sort of feel like
batman shows up to do gordon's job and
keep
yeah here they they are investigating
together and you get the sense that you
are the only person i can trust mutually
and they're learning to trust each other
in the building this is year two of
batman so you're uncovering the
corruption of gcpd and i think the way
they flushed all that out with the world
was also really well done as someone
who's seen so much batman movies seen so
many batman shows like a lot of this is
very familiar plot but to still feel
like something is very reinvigorating
and unique about this angle a nice
welcome surprise and to not have it be
ruined in trailers either was very
interesting to me and colin farrell it's
weird and the trailers i could never see
colin farrell when i was watching the
trailers but then the movie i'm like i
guess
yeah
i can pick up notes of his acting yeah
yeah exactly it's like he's so immersed
in the makeup and the character itself
so you can lose him but also he's got
his signature in there andy circus who
doesn't have as much screen time as kind
of a common rhetoric i was hearing when
the movie was done he doesn't have as
much screen time but in a lot of ways
you know it's you you could argue that
the heart and soul of this movie is
bruce wayne's relationship that strand
relationship and everything they got to
unpack there between them that's kind of
like the heart and soul of the movie for
me actually i would lean more there than
with catwoman i think a lot of people
probably apply that to catwoman as brief
as it is it lent a little bit more to
alfred for me in this film because he's
his one true ally in his one true
familial bond yeah i still feel like we
could have used a little bit more screen
time with him especially towards in the
last parts of this movie but in terms of
what we did get i was very much affected
by the performance here the music with
michael giaccino the variety that he
does i think in terms of like the genre
splicing it's captured exquisitely
through michael giaccino's score
absolutely time to strip a badass batman
movie it's always always an air of tread
the cinematography is as beautiful as
you'd expect it to be very orange the
action to it's great action but it's
maybe not as much of a stand like there
are moments within action scenes i would
say that really stand out like that car
chase scene they keep freaking showing
all the time fantastic like in a theater
experience wonderful however i would say
that a lot of the hand-to-hand combat
maybe not as gripping or as exciting as
even when that first teaser trailer came
out that when it was like what the [ __ ]
nothing quite rivals the first time you
see that
you know punch medley go down and yeah
the movie isn't so concerned with making
those moments oh [ __ ] moments so much as
it is about making those moments painful
yeah it just feels like a part of the
story and the style is very specific to
the kind of movie this is that i never
found myself just like in awe of a lot
of the action scenes there are some
moments i immediately went to like but
that moment was pretty cool but that
moves right yeah yeah they still get you
hooping and hollering to a degree what
other hand-to-hand fights ever came to
the batman warehouse fight in bvs it's
not a john wick movie yeah
yeah the hand-to-hand is like harsh and
quick and it's there like you could
imagine it being a john wick movie but
it's not shot like that but that style
and that movie for bbs would not have
worked for this movie no no no it's not
the same kind of thing at all yeah it
needed to be what it was here and my
only real criticism about any of the
action moments is when he's using the
batwing suit i didn't think the visual
effects in that moment were particularly
good look very cgi which stands out in a
film where everything looks and feels
very practical it kind of had that
bobble head effect but it's not that
much of the movie i could definitely
feel the run time of this movie i did
start becoming like
okay yeah this is a little long yeah but
nothing felt like unnecessary per se but
it did take me a while to get
emotionally invested the movie takes
such a voyeuristic approach in a lot of
ways while that actually lends a lot of
weight towards the tone and the style he
actually tore the perspective
considering who batman is in this movie
and who your protagonists and main
antagonists are in the film and the
world of gotham i did find myself more
observant and not fully emotionally
invested in the character's journey
despite always being incredibly
intrigued however and i really mean this
i don't think it'll be the same way for
everyone and i don't think it'll be the
same way for me on my second go around
with this film because i kept wondering
like am i really going to care about the
journey but at the end i was like oh my
god i do i really owe myself well yeah
because so much of it is about people
writhing in the mud and the muck of the
mess that the city has become and all
the corruption and all that and it takes
a while to finally establish the hopeful
note and and where that comes from and i
think that's kind of a part of it
deliberately thrusts you into this cold
punishing situation that is having that
kind of effect on pretty much every
character i freaking love the movie yeah
yeah i mean like we didn't really talk
about it afterwards but no i freaking
love it either yeah
to really kind of start to articulate
how you feel but one thing is for
certain when you see it it's big and
scopic and confident and cinematic it
feels planned out to the degree that you
know the the riddler is building plans
or whatever the stream is the kind of
movie that critics will definitely love
and i i wonder what the divide might be
for fans this really big wonder the only
real reason why i say this is because
while this movie is fantastic in my
opinion it's also so different than any
live-action batman film and it doesn't
quite elicit the same emotional reaction
the trailers do it's much more different
especially because it's not quite aiming
to be a crowd pleaser but i do hope that
majority end up loving it you know i
really can't tell if it'll be divisive
or not so yeah guys it's awesome i don't
know where i'd rank it yet but right now
it's a
high recommendation so it's a solid
batman out of batman it's gonna take
some processing for some people i didn't
realize i loved it until while talking
about it right now yeah yeah yeah it's
not the crowd-pleasing popcorn movie but
what's been so satisfying to me in this
discussion has just been like wow how
much of yeah this feels like a batman
film we get to talk about it feels like
the next progression beyond into just
this feels like a full-fledged cinematic
film that could have come out without
comic book source material you know all
right guys well that's it keep a lookout
for spoiler talk catch you guys soon
thanks for being here
you